ali déjà comment ça va un peu mieux
comme vous avez vraiment je suis soigné
je peux me reposer de temps en temps ça
fait du bien cet habit mais quand même
ah oui de plus la tête de l'humérus
fracture du pied une ecchymose au genou
bien les rap et au visage je suis
retrouvé à l'arcade
les mains votre aîné sean aussi la main
droite
mais ça va quand même j'avais peur pour
votre vie en ligne vous êtes dit je vais
j'ai pensé mais j'ai eu peur quand même
donné tout esquinté quoi je pensais que
j'allais m'en sortir mais j'ai eu peur
des taux est flat et j'avais 68 ans est
de noisy-le-sec je vais avoir 68 ans
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire ce qui s'est passé parce que vous
êtes très connu à nous il sait qu'à
venir inséré au oui je tenais beaucoup
moins chaud c'est voilà chez les potes
géant servi je fais des courses pour les
savait exactement le lait des figures
est où exactement il faut le dire ali à
noisy-le-sec douala dans ses banlieues
je connais très bien voilà mesdames
humeur qui est un ami proche d'amy mais
qui va raconter voilà il voilà donc il
fait les courses il rend des services
valley tools le connaît c'est un truc de
fou c'est à dire voilà il m'a dit où mon
l'aiment tout le monde le connaît c'est
ça aussi nous est son nom c'est vraiment
un bonbon la france c'est à dire ça ali
il a grandi à noisy avec vous avez eu
votre bac à 17 ans c'est ça je sais ça
j'ai passé 17 ans
il n'a pas il a pas l'ombre d'eux
l'once de méchanceté c'est ça il est
très gentil il est attentionné la preuve
en est c'est que quand ils l'ont traîné
c'est parce qu'il a eu la gentillesse de
leur donner de cigarettes cela on va
vous assurer qu'on appelait qu'est ce
qui s'est passé voilà il était monsieur
lui ce matin à dimanche 9 janvier mais
c'est heureux car j'ai eu le temps bus
7h25 gmt jeanne d'arc à 7h30 le temps de
marcher jusqu'à jusque vers la pyramide
il veut être 7h40 qui était à 45 parce
que je suis passé là bas on voit qu'il
avait des sous du lien d'accord je suis
allé j'ai rencontré que le gros 4 ils
étaient quatre cependant une clio
blanche d'accord vous les connaissez
c'est juste et ses garçons le conducteur
je connais de vue il dira bus venir
consommer au bar le ici et nulle part
ailleurs ça s'appelle d'accord il donc
là il vous est qu'est-ce qui se passe il
m'a demandé si gareth d'accord a dit ali
il m'appelait donc il me connaissait
madi ali est ce que tu insignia du loup
et 8 ans de l'une est sorti mon paquet
oui sortir une cigarette il m'a pris la
main m'a dit maintenant tu vas courir il
a accéléré avec la voiture sur 100 m
shelly lâchement à l'as mois et demi
tombé au bout de cent mètres il m'a
lâché je me suis creusé la tête que sur
le macadam et diverses contusions et des
fractures après s'est déclaré ensuite
parce que j'y ai mes protégés de bras
gauche mais j'ai pas réussi
c'est
horrible aussi je vous sens
très triste très très ému de voir ça je
me dis si j'échoue entre la tristesse et
la colère ça premier abord
j'en ai de lyon j'avais été voir paris
saint germain j'ai vu la vidéo avant de
savoir que c'était mon oncle
et je veux montrer mon ami et je lui dis
regarde ce qu'ils font c'est sous ce ne
sont pas deux familles n'ont pas d'amis
c'est quoi ces gens à quoi il joue et
une heure après j'apprends que c'est mon
oncle
et comment vous expliquer sur le moment
j'avais qu'une envie c'est de nouveau
rendre justice vous même exactement et
j'ai plusieurs choses à dire que déjà je
voudrais remercier
cyril de nous inviter ici à la plata
me dit pékin express a fait les
recherches pour retrouver les cakes
mehdi pékin express qui travaillent à
nos côtés pour toujours en poste médical
nous a accompagné un amour de mecs je
laime ce mec et c'est lui qui a retrouvé
ali
bravo à lui ils ont fait le nécessaire
on n'a pas les mots on n'a pas les mots
la seule chose qui était importante à
dire ce soir
effectivement j'étais très en colère
je crois que quelqu'un de nature calme
déjà
ni moi ni ma famille mais on a demandé à
tous d'apaiser les choses c'est ça parce
que on va le dire la famille devant
l'aris heures et eux ils n'ont rien à
voir là n'ont rien à voir régime et sont
menacés ils ont touristes je les ai eus
au téléphone j'ai eu un des frères voilà
deux de l'agresseur de l'ambiance il
exactement qui m'a dit on ne trouve ça
dégueulasse vraiment on veut qu'il soit
puni pour ce qu'ils ont fait parce que
c'est inadmissible nous aujourd'hui on
est menacé on est on peut plus sortir on
en est on est on est triste parce que je
ne cautionne pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
et on espère vraiment que voilà avec la
police et que la justice va faire son
travail parce qu on ne cautionne pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé juste nous on
est désolé pour ali on est désolé pour
sa famille et qu'on soit pris à partie
et qu'aujourd'hui on peut plus sortir
qu'on soit menacé c'est la double peine
pour nous parce que déjà on a une peine
immense de ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est c'est horrible et qu' on est on
est on est triste on les voit là de voir
quelqu'un de notre famille faire ça mais
en plus les gens du quartier les gens
tout on nous menace et au monde nous
tombe dessus ces énoncés s'est repris
par les partis politiques
voilà c'est ça à lui seul sait les mots
et mahut 6 de toute la france on voit
bien c'est un maghrébin issu de
l'immigration banlieusards musulmans on
a tout sorti là dessus je suis alors que
c'est juste un imbécile un imbécile qui
a fait une bêtise énorme mais à quel âge
l'agresseur 24 ans j'ai créé 20 à 24 ans
sont trois dans la voiture apparemment
bon moment où tu m'avais dit qu'ils
étaient 4 mais je crois que c était vrai
qu'elles sont morts de rire ils sont
hilares je crois qu'en plus c'est une
mouvance c'est à dire qu'elle n'est pas
seule c'est que d'autres personnes
s'amusent à faire ça c'est un jeu de tir
et les gens je crois qu'il a fait à une
fille de 24 ans il faut avoir le courage
68 ans
pendant toutes les capacités une petite
fille de 24 ans jeudi un moment donné ça
s'arrête quand quant à ce qu' ils n'ont
pas de grand frère ils ont pas de
grandes leur quartier qui leur explique
on est issu lui aussi des quartiers on
nous a élevés on nous a éduqués on
connaît le bien le mal le mal tout le
monde sait le faire c'est facile hein
c'est le bien acquis et plusieurs
affaires et un lit toute sa vie il a
fait du bien de lui y a pas une personne
de sa veut dire qu'il a fait je sais je
voilà c'est quand même sexe etc c'est
une mascotte s'est uni londres monde lem
voilà ali ali aujourd'hui est ce que
vous avez reçu des pressions pour
retirer votre plainte ou des oui oui non
une pression mais hier matin il ya un
jeune homme de 25 ans comme ça qui est
venu vers moi qui m'a dire place du
marchix j'étais vers la place du marchix
et m'a dit si tu retires ta plante le
gars il te donne 1000 euros ce soir et
je dédie au commissariat je redis je
n'acceptais pas ils disent qu'ils
m'avaient dit qu'ils n'acceptaient pas
parce que j'avais pas des séquelles et
toute cette durée longtemps il y avait
des soins et puis même c'est pas honnête
quoi lui dit non tout tue-le tue-le tu
leur en veut énormément à ses jeunes et
qu'est ce tu envie de dire à leurs
familles parce que je sais que la
famille logan et leurs familles qui sont
jolis sont dans une détresse incroyable
aussi pages comprend bien mais je
préfère les ignorer
il m'emmène pas moins le palais les voir
à lille est passé à autre chose ouais à
lille et passe à autre chose c'est pas
quelqu'un de ma famille l'objet nommé
liège j'aime bien avec eux je suis
content qu est ce que tu t'es dit quand
ça s'est passé tu t'es dit quoi tu t'es
dit je vais appeler ma famille je vais
je veux vraiment me venger ou tu t'es
dit je l'espère aller mieux c'est tout
ce que j'espère n'ont ils espèrent aller
mutuel et au commissariat directement
pour porter plainte parce que c'est
normal mais j'ai pas pensé
tu pensais que j'allais lui fait pas de
mal alors non
je veux qu'il soit enfermé soignés s'ils
sont malades pour toi c'est des malades
sein je sais c'est chez points qui sont
malades qui abusent de droit ou ne sais
pas ils soient soignés en moins alors
sur la vidéo on voit un deuxième homme
se faire traîner comme vous et il
demandait d'arrêter est-ce que vous
les avis des nouvelles de 2,7 on sait
même pas qui c'est c'est en fait sur la
vidéo c'est le premier camion se pacser
le deuxième on entend bien la voix de
mon nom qui dit mais arrête m'arrête
arrête tes conneries je vais tomber je
vais ils sont morts de rire trop pour
lui adresser un mois assez jaune ce soir
non j'ai rien à leur dire vraiment
honnêtement j'ai rien à leur dire les
jeunes qu'on fait ça non j'ai rien à
l'audience et la justice à jeanne alors
exactement ça la justice n'y a pas parlé
si heureusement que cicéron d'hier soir
alors on va rappeler le cas d un
accident du
chauffeur les deux fils les deux un
premier suivi un rendez vous que les
policiers lui ont donné sur un parking
le deuxième est venu au commissariat
effectivement il sentait qu avec des
menaces sur eux et leur famille ils sont
tous les deux en garde à vue pour
violences volontaires aggravées sur
personne vulnérable et maintenant les
enquêteurs recherchent effectivement il
ya un lit à la jeune femme de 24 ans au
moins troisième homme non identifié
les enquêteurs cherchent à savoir s'il
ya d'autres victimes avant une
éventuelle mise en examen alors quels
sont les chefs d'accusation alors ces
violences volontaires aggravées sur
personne vulnérable parce que alliés et
vulnérables et donc ça peut aller
jusqu'à cinq ans de prison
éventuellement la justice a agi tout de
suite avec la plateforme pharos et la
violence est là on va parler d'un autre
chef d'accusation aussi ce serait
tortures et actes de barbarie oui oui
parce que ça dépasse le cadre de la
violence il y aurait la vidéo qui est
il ya le conducteur et puis à celui qui
a fait la vidéo qu'il a diffusée est-ce
qu'ils auraient pas prémédité ce qu'ils
ont fait est effectivement jusqu'à subi
ali on est sûr de la barbarie est là ça
peut être passible de 10 ou 20 même 20
ans de prison ça peut être très très
graves apparemment surpris au
conditionnel mais ce serait pas la
première fois oui ça alors les suspects
connus défavorablement des services de
leur volume ans le conducteur donc on
respecte totalement sa famille et lui il
a déjà été condamné pour vol usage de
stupéfiants et infraction au code de la
route